yeah kind of cute what does that even
mean
I really don't want to turn my time for
me I lower it no no finally you know can
I lower it why cuz they hate sounds eat
it it's learning to read it I don't know
I've only played if I can lower it a
little bit they can you play legend if
you want the volume you have to play
then the breaks kid them's the breaks
[ __ ] take the remote but take the
remote Jen you do you want volume watch
out is what made me know this oh you're
supposed to look at all these checks I
won't know what they mean it means
you've been here Billy and time yeah I
got it does - yeah it does that's been
there a billion you like that how much
are there probably a billion I've been
have you ever been going around a
billion so it didn't happen something I
mean yes
oh it's you're walking this is your
fault
what do you wanted the bomb where the
gap in the door
what does that mean you turned the
volume up and I don't like sound what
was that what's that radio okay we're I
think we check this room I don't
actually know her is that I think she
comes up soon but now I'm alright now
[ __ ] kills us again like last time
beneath the window I'm releasing the
window I know through the one don't look
at the window just look down on the [ __ ]
oh before look at the bear look at the
bear no it's just
four eight six three two zero two zero
four eight six three eight six three the
quanto date I don't feel like that
doesn't mean anything but there was a
it's just a [ __ ] do you want to check
for the piece of mat and the options
menu again first option maybe you like
mess with stuff yeah shaking graphic on
side oh my god what is that it's closed
you have to go let's go look the
bathroom bathroom
it's get the backup all right I think we
have one one left
check this boy or whatever what the frig
happen is the fridge oh god your eyes
out the painting right up
oh yeah not open before you go through
the door I mean that door look at the
stairs I mean go down the few steps and
then turn around look at the steps
yeah yeah peace see it's like oh it's
just yeah right there yes yep okay all
right you're you're done you're because
you made us do this
this is your idea
brilliant plan what do we do with okay
right yeah go to the people there should
be a hole in the wall now get over it
no a little it paintings done I don't
know I just keeps not do anything
yeah yeah no stops turning I'm Russell
ever again I'm cool what happens now
I have no idea it's kind of I don't
remember but this the fridge happens a
free toppings but I don't know when that
happens it's probably this time I really
[ __ ] you piss too much well the baby
super labs now he's baby crying like
fries I don't want to do it I don't want
to do it if [ __ ] hate it the gangster
because this [ __ ] place is a mess
like a weird toilet look up there's a
fridge right no no fridge alright cool
see you guys both I'll gather with
motive stuffs in I can hear me I can
hear him calling to me from from from
Henley Oh read that we give me at least
a dozen once you're inside of me no yeah
no forgiveness for you so differently
how like pop music playing in the rap
yeah she's just put up some smooth jazz
can we go to Spotify to Iceland oh boy
yeah you put Spotify khana you get done
you get the grand finale can you please
can we listen the Miley Cyrus why do we
have to get the Ritz my yeah yeah only
you
in my head I feel okay I'm just for a
second this says I think I'm calling to
me for huh from hell phone from hell yes
but I don't remember how to get it to
say hey I forgot there is the thing that
you need to do we have to like a look at
a bunch of [ __ ] that makes it say help
I forgot you yeah I forgot what it was I
can bring my phone I got no I don't
remember my heart races I feel like okay
so I'm constantly feeling I have to pee
my pants
yeah yes I'm like so good again that's
what I'm like I'll have to pee all the
time I don't want to be my hair I know
that the fridge happens you need to say
hell in a kitchen just till tummy yeah
it's it's not really it's just all yeah
you need that noise I don't know but
it's fun does the can't get old ear at
all now I think he's about the same I
just moved in here to stare at this
whole time okay what is the noise oh
it's the fridge it's the fridge I really
don't want to turn around we don't I'm
sorry
getting less cute is it is it you want
to play no no you should say no I don't
want like I'm so sweaty yeah I'm making
this control as many things available I
don't want to what legend
no I can't I bring my physically yeah
yeah no sorry no that's why I played
forget [ __ ] right now I'm so scared